hi there uh big dogs I'm trying to get
home I know which way that is oh great
right up my ass oh no that can't be
right this is Will Ferrell I'm lost
you're a stray man you can do anything
you want this beer doesn't taste good
but I like how it's making me feel this
is Jamie Foxx how recently took this
couch
and she dirty too no well I I can tell
looks like she hasn't been washed in
years I'll see you later baby it was
nice to meet you I really should find my
way back home any places landmarks you
remember I remember the devil in the sky
look at that fine hell mother son of a
dumps
we're completely lost and my little
puppy paw pads are really hurting right
now this could be a lot worse how could
this get worse
that is the craziest thing I have ever
seen
and I'm Dennis Quaid and Dennis Quaid
has seen some
I'm starving how many of these should we
eat all of them give me a sec whoa you
look different you look different too
how so is it my human hands hold up
the cops oh God what do we do calm down
I got this hello officer none of us shut
the up Strays in theaters August 18
rated R